six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty let's continue seeing what's
on people's minds we'll go to our next
caller from the three zero one area code
who's this what's on your mind hello
this is you're on the air right now oh
wow listen a minute hold it let's before
we go any further if we're on
speakerphone please take us off and
we're gonna need you to speak up as much
as possible I can barely hear you okay
hold on thank you son okay can you get
me now it's marginally better okay sorry
I'm I'm actually outside my question is
that what is your opinion on the
fairness doctrine that was discontinued
in 1987 I honestly believe that we
should try to reinstate that so that we
can at least stop all this polarizing
news media I wanted to know what your
opinions and thoughts were about that
okay good
so I believe that and I've actually
taught quite a bit about this in the
course I'm teaching at Boston College
this semester I believe that the goals
of the Fairness Doctrine are our goals
that I share in terms of what I would
like to see the end result of media be
however as you talked about it's been
some time since we had the Fairness
Doctrine and I believe that we maybe
need a different approach at this time
that would be both more relevant given
the technological changes that we've
seen over the last couple of decades
when it comes to media consumption and
wit the ways people get information and
I like the idea of using net neutrality
and the regulation of the Internet as a
common carrier to sort of try to tackle
some fraction of the problems that the
Fairness Doctrine was was meant to sort
of sort of solve so I am sort of
agnostic as to whether that the Fairness
Doctrine is reinstated but I think that
from a practical perspective we might
want to think I mean it's 2017 we might
want to be rebuilding a new
infrastructure for the regulation of
media rather than just restarting
something like the Fairness Doctrine
but if that's the case and how you able
to regulate new and online media that's
not you care from YouTube and Facebook
because if you try to do that then it's
a violation of the First Amendment
because it's of whose cause the way is
coming from because then you have people
like Alex Jones and Bill O'Reilly saying
whatever they want without any kind of
factual back and go evidence right
you're absolutely correct but my
question to you would be how would the
Fairness Doctrine deal with infowars.com
I guess the thing is that you can't
really call it and do the operational
site that if you have that the thing
that you do with anything news then you
have to strictly go under the Fairness
Doctrine but there's a bigger issue
there's a bigger issue as well which is
the the bigger issue in sorry the bigger
issue that exists there is once you
start getting into if it's not illegal
content that a website has if the
content is not illegal in some way then
it is very dangerous to start passing
laws that would impact the specific not
illegal content of web sites I think
it's dangerous oh I see they just that I
guess I'm just going to find a way to
like combat this whole fake news thing
like legitimately yeah things that
Fairness Doctrine I just don't and I've
done we check out our long-form piece
about fake news because we talked a
little bit towards the end about ways to
combat fake news and I don't I don't
have time to delve into it here but I
don't but I don't think the Fairness
Doctrine is the solution so check that
video out I will and I just wanna say
thank you for having me on the show I'm
a huge fan
my pleasure No thank you so much for
calling in and on that note we will go
to a break and answer your questions
coming up next give us a like on
Facebook facebook.com slash David Pakman
show and remember that your
contributions of as little as a single
dollar per month at patreon.com slash
david pakman show support the
five-day-a-week david pakman show